hello everyone so welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily so it's always
been my dream to be a speaker which led
me to quit my day job to pursue this
full-time and all of you are coming
along for this journey with me so in
every episode I take on a different
challenge to really help me grow as a
speaker so in this video I'm going to be
filming at Yonge and Dundas Square the
busiest intersection in Toronto because
I learned from Rene Brown that if
there's something meaningful that I want
to do I need to have the courage to show
up if I want to be a successful speaker
I need to be able to deliver my speech
whenever wherever in front of whoever so
wish me luck and I hope everything goes
well alright so today is a day I'm gonna
be filming at Yonge and Dundas Square to
be honest with you I think leading up to
it I felt so nervous even like a month
ago when I thought about this idea
people staring at me is going to be such
an anxiety provoking experience but I
actually feel really good I feel more
excited than anything else I don't know
I don't know what it is maybe it's just
thinking about it over and over again or
it could be
I have been practicing more in the last
month I don't know but you know I'm
right here at my house things could be
very different when I get there so we'll
see how it goes so we left our house my
lovely husband is gonna look at your
hair oh my goodness it was like man bun
to the max anyway he's gonna drive me to
the Go station I'm gonna take the GO
train to the downtown Toronto Wow look
at that hair she thinks she's all tough
hey but wait til I drop her off at the
ghost issue she's good like she's gonna
start quaking in her oh yeah okay we'll
see we'll see
I didn't realize I actually missed the
last train I came to the station a
little too late
it's either on the trains run really
early in the morning like around like
5:00 a.m. or really late in the
afternoon so I'm gonna be taking the bus
I hope I'm standing in the right spot I
had some lovely lovely gentlemen over
there and the Blue Jays shirt that that
pointed me in the right direction so I
have a new friend here that helped me
out and point him in the right direction
what's your name hi there I'm Greg and
I'm from Barrie and heading down to Blue
Jay games and Lilly tells me that today
she's gonna try to face her fears that's
what this episode is about and it's
about facing fears and she's gonna ride
the run filming in public is gonna be
your big thing yeah so that's pretty
cool yeah that's exciting
do you have a few I don't I don't have
any fears that I know about nothing yeah
I'm not fearless I'm sure you know
there's always the fear of not being
successful or not taking care of your
family those are always the common ones
but other than that no nothing really
one of those things all right you just
push through their fear I do yeah yeah
you just learned to cope and you learn
to do it all right thank you thank you I
got to another station I'm supposed to
take another bus from here it was
interesting I got to meet a gentleman
named Greg and after he did the video we
started talking and then he said that
he's into leadership stuff too and how
he guides his um his employees to become
better leaders I never used to approach
strangers is something that I had
another fear of but you know sometimes
approaching strangers you never know you
could learn a lot from them so something
something good came out of it
all right guide so I'm finally here
downtown it took a long time I was on
the bus for about two and a half hours
I'm actually really hungry I'm gonna go
find something to eat and then take
another subway up to Yonge and Dundas
Square
so I'm actually for you for those who
don't know downtown Toronto I'm really
south and Yonge and Dundas is about 20
minutes from here but I'm gonna go grab
some food then go to the bathroom - I
gotta go
[Music]
well I found a washroom and I got my
food so I'm going to try to find it
somewhere that I guess said and eat
before I do my big filming at Yonge and
Dundas Square so I finally got to Yonge
and Dundas Square and I realized that I
messed up
I forgot my I forgot my big tripod I
don't know I left it in my husband's car
so I have my little one that Nina gave
me so I'm gonna try to use that also
another thing is I got here and there's
like me I mean they're people here but
it's nowhere close to as busy as I was
expecting so I don't know I don't know
I'm thinking maybe I should find a
busier place downtown to film because
really I think there's about I don't
even know like maybe 50 people around I
was expecting hundreds maybe even a
thousand but I hope you thought I don't
know it or not it's a Friday afternoon I
haven't done to us and there's no one
around
anyway I'll try to figure it out and
yeah I'll start filming soon oh I just
found out that they are doing a
Chevrolet Auto Show here so they're
blocking out Yonge and Dundas Square
that's why no one's around
so I also can't film there either I'm
going to walk down the street and
probably go to Queen Street West which
is another really busy part of downtown
Toronto so I'm going to try doing that
and yeah you know life happens you gotta
just you gotta adjust when when things
don't go exactly as planned
so we'll see well see we'll see
everything every opportunity is an
opportunity learn guys all the time
[Music]
all right I found a busier place I'm
actually at the Toronto Civic Center I
believe it's called this is where we
hold our LR events but there's like
different exhibits that's going on right
now lots of people around not as much as
I would like I don't know what I was
expecting I think what I wanted to do
this event I pictured thousands of
people around me but I don't know maybe
this is how busy it always is I all made
it up in my head that it's supposed to
be a lot busier anyway so it looks like
they're gonna have a concert soon so
kind of give you a glimpse oh there's a
food truck there oh look there's our
beautiful Toronto Toronto sign right
there okay so I'm gonna try to find a
place to set up my little tripod cuz I
lost my big one and yeah it's gonna
happen testing testing testing since I'm
here at my first attempt in shooting I
realize that a my little bit too far
away from the action of a Civic Centre
and primarily because I couldn't find
anything to put my tripod on so I have
to use my creativity to go right in the
middle of all the action
yeah that's a point of all of this the
point of all of this is for me to face
my fear and being around a lot of people
and I was kind of far away from people
so it's a good check-in for myself yeah
let me go find some place
so I found a busier place to set up but
the only thing is that there was no
for me to set up my tripod so I have the
tripod on a bench and I'm sitting on the
floor which kind of adds to the
awkwardness of this which is great
because that's what I'm looking for and
I think people probably wondering why am
i sitting on the floor and recording but
hey that's part of the challenge
hey everyone so as I'm here at downtown
Toronto facing my fear in filming in
public I thought I'd share some tips and
how to overcome your fear or at least
push through it the number one thing to
always think about is how is your fear
holding you back so for example I want
to be a speaker and I'm going to be in
situations where I'm gonna be speaking
in front of many people that I have I've
never met I have no idea if they care
about me like me or they may hate
everything I have to say so I have to
overcome that I'm not always going to
have the comfort of my own backyard
filming where's everything is safe and
it's my home and nobody else is looking
at me or have the comfort and going to
the TDS studio where it's only Evan and
our camera person so I needed to push
through that fear and thinking that how
it's been holding me back all my life
really helped me go through this process
and really kind of diminish all the fear
that I had in filming in public now then
here's Ashley not bad I don't feel that
anxiety anymore that I used to it was my
moment
[Music]
it's mostly all in my head and when
you're there it's actually not that bad
the number two thing that you want to
think about is to start small you don't
want to go from being like completely
petrified in doing something and then
completely flooding your system and
going crazy so for me I had a fear in
filming in public so I started off
filming while I was walking on a
sidewalk then I then I started filming
in a grocery store and then I started
filming where my class was going on and
a little by little it kind of helped me
build a muscle to face my biggest fear
which is coming here downtown and
filming in front of all these people
around me and that really really helps
so when you want to think about it
like if you have a fear of swimming
maybe you want to try out in your
bathtub first and then go to a shallow
end of a pool and then later on you
could go to a deep end of a pool so
little by little you're gonna train
yourself to overcome that fear and
number three is to keep pushing this
because you've conquered one fear
doesn't mean that you're gonna stop
there so for me I've conquered this a
fear in filming in public it doesn't
really feel like a fear anymore so now I
need to think about what's next for me
and keep pushing through and not be
content that I I mean guess I'm happy
that I overcame this fear but I need to
keep going through so I think the next
thing I want to do is like go on a big
stage and speak in front of a lot of
a lot hundreds of people that's what I
would like to do
so I finished out filming my little
piece by setting up an event it was
interesting it was good I mean I had to
do what I could with the situation I was
in I can't believe I left my tripod in
my husband's car but I had to use my
creativity to kind of maneuver maneuver
maneuver the right where does a man ooh
Oh manure okay anyways that's not the
point
maneuver around the obstacles but more
importantly it's it's beautiful here
I used to live downtown I lived downtown
Toronto for about six years before
moving up north and I love it here the
energy is so vibrant the people are so
wonderful and everyone's so diverse and
there's always something going on so I
that part I really miss about living in
the city I'm gonna take a walk around
and look at this exhibit that's going on
it's Paul noblank brain project so I'm
into the love and then I'm going to head
home and go see my husband
[Music]
hey so I'm back at Union Station it's so
interesting here there's lots of stuff
going on anyway I have about half an
hour to kill so I'm going to get online
and answer some of your comments because
my unlocking Lilly episode six no five
five five just came out yeah I'm excited
to see what you guys wrote
[Music]
just got off the train gonna go see the
husband look how beautiful it is it's
not just nice yeah
what a change of scenery from crazy
downtown Toronto to farmland Beauty look
who I found
it's my husband happy to see me oh yeah
you happy to see you too so I just got
back from filming in public kind and it
was not nearly as bad as I thought it
would be initially I was like playing up
all these scenarios leading up to it
what if people stare at me weird what if
I accidentally drop my phone
what if people judge me what if people
say things to me and honestly no one
cared everyone was going along their
merry way
everything was fine people were having a
great time I think some people did kind
of look over but you know it was out of
curiosity and not like sheer judgment
maybe they were judging I don't know but
I feel great about it I was so happy to
be there at Downtown in the midst of all
the action I did have a few obstacles
that I had to kind of use my creativity
to kind of work around but it all worked
out in the end and that goes to show
that fear is sometimes just in your head
and when you go out and do it it's not
as bad as you thought originally which
brings me to the next point so the
question of the day is what is your
biggest fear that you still have yet to
overcome write in the comments below and
I'll join in on the discussion so for my
next challenge I'm going to go into an
event and start with my why because I
learned from simon Sinek
instead of going with what you do and
how you do it you need to start with why
so thank you so much for watching and I
really hope you enjoyed my journeys from
downtown Toronto it was a lot of fun for
me and I actually have a special shout
out for halona black so halona black
wrote how exciting it's great to have a
mentor who can push you to do things
that you may not feel ready for
I need to do more of this for myself
yes Ilona black it is true I do have a
bomb of a mentor Evan and he is so
wonderful and he unleashes all sorts of
belief on me when I needed the most and
I wouldn't be able to do a lot of the
things I have done recently if it wasn't
for him so so so thankful for the lovely
Evan so when I first started out on this
series I thought it was just a way for
me to document my journey and show some
transparency to you guys as well but I
had no idea that it would be inspiring
for you and it would inspire you to do
the things that you want to do and I am
completely at a loss of words of all the
wonderful comments I think pouring in I
can't thank you enough and be grateful
enough and I really do hope that one day
I'll be able to meet all of you in
person but if I don't it makes me feel
good that we're all in this together and
we're going on this journey arm and arm
thank you thank you thank you so much
and I will see you guys very very soon